(audience applauding)
All right, Ross and Drew.
Everyone knows that entertainment news waits for no one,
a lot has happened since I last saw you on Monday.
So, I'm going to quiz you
with the very latest pop culture headlines.
Let's see how much you know, okay? Are you ready?
Well, we did really well last time,
which makes me even more nervous this time.
Yeah. I don't want to brag, but we were four for four.
Yes, you did. You crushed it, you crushed it.
Okay. Well, now that you've laid down the gauntlet,
let's get in it.
Okay.
All right.
Question number one of the pop culture show down.
What singer just made the huge announcement
that she is expecting her first child?
Is it Ariana Grande, Halsey or Taylor Swift?
B. Halsey.
(audience cheering)
Wow. You are on the money,
that's right.
(Drew celebrating)
She's expecting her first child.
Halsey popped on Instagram
and she didn't really announce it.
She just said, "Surprise!"
Holding her belly and that means, I'm having a baby.
You got it right.
Yeah, we saw it. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Question number two.
What pop star just tried their first pole dance workout,
and posted it on Instagram?
Is it Megan Thee Stallion, Miley Cyrus or Harry Styles?
Oh no. I spoke way too soon.
I don't know,
but my gut is going Megan.
Me too.
Is that what you were thinking?
Yes. All right. We're totally guessing on this one.
Lock us in on Megan.
Drew and Ross, you are absolutely right.
It is Meg Thee Stallion.
Oh my gosh!
(audience applauding)
She is kicking off her two weeks,
hottie bootcamp with a pole dance.
It's a personal health and fitness journey for her.
So, you are right.
You're still, you still haven't missed a question.
Okay. Two for two.
Okay. Number three.
Which music star just snag their first leading role
in a movie that requires them to dress up
as an elderly person and blend in at a nursing home.
Is it Adele, Cardi B or Justin Bieber?
I haven't, I don't think Adele. Right.
I just don't, I don't think so.
I think B.
You're right.
Okay Drew, I'm with you, Cardi B.
Oh gosh. We're going to go Cardi B, B.
You are right again.
Oh my gosh, Drew.
(audience applauding)
I can't believe this. I can't believe it.
I can't believe it either.
Cardi starring in a new movie called,
"Assisted Living."
She's a criminal hiding out from the police
and she dresses up as an elderly woman and goes into a home.
This is like "Sister Act" in an elderly home.
I loved it.
(Kevin laughing)
Well, and I left her in "Hustlers"
and I know she's interested in acting
and she's just so playful and cool, my gut went to Cardi B.
Okay, Phew! God.
Okay. Here we go.
What blockbuster rom-com, which grows $93 million worldwide,
turns 20, this year?
Is it "The Wedding Planner",
"How to Lose a Guy in 10 Days", or "Bride Wars"?
Hey, it would be the oldest of those, wouldn't it?
Jennifer Lopez and Matthew McConaughey,
just did an IgG live.
So I say, A.
A, A.
YouTube pop culture world, (indistinct).
(audience cheers)
You're right again.
Drew, you saw that Instagram live
where they talked about their instant chemistry
and how hot it was.
And the first kiss at the movie theater
where he turned her,
and they were just about to have their first smooch
because the scene required it.
And he said to her, "Ms. Lopez, I'm going to kiss you now."
(table bangs)
Now, look, normally if you're a wife
and you're sitting at home
and you watch your husband go on Instagram live
and talk about his instantaneous connection
with another woman, you'd be a little worried
because it's J-Lo
but he's married to Camilla Alvarez, please.
She's like, "Go on, do your thing."
She's the most beautiful woman
on the planet, Camilla Alvarez and it's weird,
it's like when you go to work it's not as sexy
as you would think on a set where they're like,
literally like,
"You got to go to the left. We can't see your face."
And you're just like,
(speaking gibberish).
and there's a lot of people standing around
and, you know, some people are bored and not into it.
And you know, it's hard almost to get lost in those moments.
So I think for people who know,
you're like, "It's it's work.
It's the best job on the planet."
Kissing Matthew McConaughey
I was gonna say,
kissing a guy on a pitching mound is pretty fun too, right?
I mean, a pretty hot guy on a pitching mound.
Right, I'm not going to lie.
I love my job when I get to kiss these wonderful gentlemen.
I mean, come on.
It's the Hugh Grant, Adam Sandler,
like it's the greatest job in the world.
Am I the only male CoStar you haven't kissed Drew?
(everyone laughing)
Yet, it's early.
I mean, do you even fantasize about that Ross,
probably not.
We've got to go to break.
(Drew and Ross laughs)
All right. Let's get a, can we sneak in another one?
Okay, here we go.
Yes.
For Valentine's day,
rapper Post Malone said he is giving 10,000 of these
to frontline workers at 70 hospitals across America.
Is it weighted blankets, pool noodles or crocs?
It's 100% see crocs.
Oh. Drew, Drew are you sure?
Yes, because I used to be their brand ambassador.
And then he was the next one.
And he still currently is, I believe.
Are we right?
Those crocs are red hot.
Everybody in the world wants them, they are sold out.
But the frontline workers will get them.
And Drew, once again, you are on the money.
(Drew laughing)
(audience applauding)
And by the way,
we here at ET are still waiting for our Drew crocs.
We're just going to all wear our Drew crocs one day, okay.
So you, y'all send them on over.
They're just such a cool company.
They totally get it.
And yeah, Post Malone and Bieber,
they're all working with them.
And I'm really glad to see that ost Malone is doing that
because I think he is so cool.
Mm Hmm. Yep. You guys own the pop culture world.
Look at all these questions, you just throwing them away.
Kevin, let's do this again, please.
Not just a game per week. (chuckles)
Are you in?
I am in forever. I'm ready.
I'll be back next week if you call me, okay.
Thank you so much. Catch Kevin on Entertainment Tonight,
every week night, obviously.
(gentle upbeat music)